Mì chỉ thống bơi, giám đốc quy bán, anh em cú ra, Bella Rose, KGB, ông Yvang, Chá Tréo Chó Bien,
có quan này đang tìm cách thích lập để lạc với dưới trước u quay nà, nhằm túc đầy mũ dải pháp hoa bình cho cô xương đột
kéo dài đã hưởng bà nằm dưới dựa kiét và mắt cơvà. Ông Chá Tréo Nhân Mạnh, chỉ cứ đối thoại và toa hiệp,
mới có thể giải quyết năng thằng hiện nay, đông thời hàng định Bella Rose đang cố gắng vui chỉ, cán cân lời ex ở các bên.
Bella Rose vốn đã đồng muynh thân cận của Ngá và tân cho phát mắt cơvà sử dụng lạnh thổ để phát động trí dịch quần xử năm 2020.
Mọi giù tổng thống Alixang đỡ lúc cao xen cô không đưa quần trực tiếp tham chiến, nhưng Bella Rose cũng chỉ ở lạnh trường phát từ phần tay từng đường ngá.
Gần đây, ông lúc cao xen cô bài tỏ mong bộn đối phói trực tiếp với tổng thống quần á vô đi mey ra lệski để tìm đau ra trong cuộc sôn đột.
Trong buổi cảnh, tổng thống biết đồ năng trăm kèo quản Bella Rose, đồng vài cho xây dân trong tế trình hoặc bình, tổ lạnh sẽ được giám của lập.
Cụp lên quán tự quốc xong đột, cũng ngay bị chiến thống gây, tổng thống của quen á dệ lệski kèo quán gií và cho ao, còn những bước đi quyết đoán sau chuyển tổng giù mi mà không đã được kết quán về việc nhận được tên lửa tấm xa tổ mà hó.
Tại cuộc gà phép ông Zelenski tổng thống cho biết các cuộc chào đối rất thân mặt sau chiến mạnh đã để lúc ngà vụ quay nào tân được bản và chấm giúp sông đột mà không được giảm quyết định về kể hoạt cùng các lỗi tên lửa trên cho kia.